(musique religieuse)
- 200 000 pélerins étaient
rassemblés le week-end dererer
à Notre-Dame de Fatima,
au Portugal, pour prier
pour l'Ukraine.
Une foule compacte même si
le pays connaît une remontée
spectaculaire des cas de COVID
causés par deux nouveaux
variants.
En ce moment, les très
contagieux BA.4 et BA.5
connaissent une croissance
rapide en Europe et ailleurs.
En Afrique du Sud,s s s s reprt
70 % des nouveau cas;
au Portugal, près de 40 %;
on en retrouve aussi en
Allemagne, au Royaume-Uni
et de plus en plus sou
aux États-Unis.
On estime que les deux
sous-variants progressent
quotidiennement au rythme
impressionnant de 12 %.
ALAIN LAMAiriririrologue,
Institut national de recherche
- C'est amplement suffisant
pour... pour prendre le dessus
et éventuellement devenir
dominant dans une population.
- Ils ememememement, dans
une certaine mesure, la capacité
de se transmettre aux gens
vaccinés ou déjà infectées
par le variant Omi
Heureusement, la vaccination
demeure une excellente
protection.
- Même contre BA.4 et BA.5,
les données préliminaires
suggèrent que le vaccin, quand
on a reçu au moins trois doses,
nous protège quand même bien
de la maladie sévère.
- Au Canada, on ne compte que
14 cas d'infections aux BA.4
et BA.5, et seulement deux
au Québec.
Par contre, un nouveau sous-
variant, américain celui-là,
gagne du terrain : le BA.2.12.1.
Au Québec, il compte déjà pour
6 % des nouveau cas, et
les études récentes indiquent
qu'il est 25 % plus
transmissible que le plus
transmissible des variants
connus.
Bref, difficile de dire lequels
de ces nouveaux variants va être
vague.
Dre JUDITH FAFARD, Laboratoire
de santé publique du Québec
- On a des populations
différentes, des mesures
sanitaires très différentes
aux États-Unis, en Afrique
du Sud, en Europe. Donc, c'est
difficile de faire certaines
comparaisons, mais
il va y avoir probablement
une petite compétition entre ce.
- Heureusement, aucun d'entre
eux n'est considéré comme une
menace très sérieuse.
- On ne s'attend pas, comme je
vous dis, à un "game changer"
qui va faire qu'il y a plus rien
qui fonctionne... qu'on a des
grosses, grosses, grosses
surcharges de notre système.
- On a identifié des centaines
variants depuis le début
de la pandémie; seulement cinq
sont considéananananananants
par l'OMS.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Montréa